follow length focus on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram what should we do today
today let's talk about Chinese no let's
talk about wisdom Chinese no let's talk
about classical Chinese or maybe
standard Chinese no no we're going to
talk about various Chinese dialects okay
let's just talk about all of them hello
everyone welcome to the Lang focused
Channel and my name is Paul today we're
going to talk about Chinese but the big
question is what do I mean when I say
Chinese the word Chinese refers to
standard Chinese which is based on
Mandarin but it also refers to a large
group of languages and dialects open
throughout China and indeed throughout
the world Chinese languages also called
scientific languages are a subfamily of
the sino-tibetan language family Chinese
is not a single language but rather a
number of related dialect groups which
are united by a common written language
a common writing system some people
consider them all Chinese dialects but
I'm going to refer to these dialect
groups as distinct languages because in
many cases they are unintelligible all
Chinese languages are tonal languages
the meaning of a word depends on the
tone or the tones that you say it with
sure she if you change the tone the
meaning of the word changes there are
more than 1.3 billion native speakers of
Chinese if we include all its varieties
standard Chinese generally referred to
as Mandarin is the official language of
the People's Republic of China the
Republic of China also known as Taiwan
or Chinese Taipei and it's one of the
four official languages of Singapore
Chinese languages are also spoken in
lots of diaspora communities throughout
Asia like in Malaysia Indonesia and
Thailand and in different communities
around the world history the scientific
languages for the Chinese languages
developed from proto sino to Ben which
existed perhaps around 4000 BCE the
earliest written examples of Chinese are
from around 1250 BCE they were written
using a form of Chinese called the
Oracle bone script which was carved onto
turtle shells and animal
which were used for divination like a
kite of fortune-telling a more
recognizable form of old Chinese
developed during the Jo dynasty between
1046 and 256 BCE it can be found on
bronze sculptures from that time period
as well as in some literature like
classical poetry it's generally thought
that during this early time period
Chinese had not yet developed tones both
develops later in the transition to
middle Chinese the form of written
Chinese that developed between this
period and the end of the Han Dynasty in
the 3rd century CE II is known as
classical Chinese or literary Chinese
classical Chinese continues to be used
as the formal written language until the
beginning of the 20th century spoken
Chinese continues to evolve into middle
Chinese Google honey middle Chinese is
the ancestor of almost all modern
Chinese varieties the exception is min
Chinese which developed earlier maybe
during the Han period middle Chinese was
not a single unified language but
consisted of a number of mutually
intelligible dialects that began
diverging in different directions around
the 10th century CE II and you probably
hear me say that every time I talk about
a language family those local varieties
of Chinese continue to develop in their
own directions as distinct languages
over the centuries with a lot of local
dialectal variation within each language
as I mentioned before classical Chinese
was being used as the formal written
language but during this time period
written vernacular Chinese also
developed alongside it written
vernacular Chinese refers to ways of
writing Chinese that reflect the spoken
language in its different varieties
these forms of Chinese were used for
some informal writing people were
already writing in written vernacular
Chinese during the tongue and Song
dynasties from the 7th to 13th century
CE II old Mandarin Guang class after the
northern Song Dynasty and during the
Jean and un dynasties a language
recognizable as a form of Mandarin was
spoken this variety of Chinese is known
as old Mandarin the UN dynasty was a
period of mongol control of china the
wars leading up to the Mongol conquest
caused large-scale migration of old
Mandarin speakers to the south this
spread early Mandarin died
two more areas and also had an influence
on other emerging Chinese languages
middle Mandarin during the Ming and Qing
dynasties an official administrative
language was created based on the
Mandarin dialect of the capital managing
with some features of other dialects as
well this was the first point at which
the language became referred to as
Mandarin Guan hua which means speech of
officials we now refer to the stage of
the language as middle Mandarin in the
late 19th century towards the end of the
Qing Dynasty the specific dialect of
Beijing started to grow in importance
and became the new high variety of
Chinese replacing the older high variety
which was based on a number of different
dialects at the beginning of the 20th
century a form of written vernacular
Chinese based on a number of Mandarin
dialects was introduced as the new
official written language instead of
classical Chinese but it was later
decided that the new official language
should be based specifically on the
Beijing dialect this new standard
language was called poutama
which means common language or green
which means national language people
often refer to this standard language as
Mandarin because it's based on the
Mandarin dialects of Beijing but to be
precise the word Mandarin refers to a
range of northern dialects standard
Chinese or Mandarin now fulfills the
role that classical Chinese used to
fulfill as the official written language
that's used by speakers of all varieties
of Chinese for most purposes but written
vernacular languages still do exist and
are used for some informal situations so
how many varieties of Chinese are there
well that depends on how you're counting
and categorizing them but it's often
said that there are over 200 distinct
varieties of Chinese which comprise
around 13 distinct dialect groups the
local dialects within each of these
groups are often intelligible so it's
reasonable to consider these groups as
languages at least I think so
out of these 13 groups of dialects there
are seven that are generally considered
major these are Mandarin one class UA GE
Chun
Minn but Don Gani Wu and Hakka acaba the
writing system Chinese is written in
Chinese characters or hanson tongfu are
logograms single characters that
represent entire words or entire units
of meaning for example this character
means China in this character means
character as in a written character and
together they mean Chinese character or
han xue the kind we're talking about
these characters need to be learned one
by one because just knowing the
pronunciation of a word doesn't give you
any indication of how to write it
speakers of all varieties of Chinese
typically write in standard Chinese or
Mandarin even though their spoken
language is different when the reading
standard Chinese out loud they'll
probably pronounce each character the
way it's pronounced in their local
variety of Chinese this has led to the
common misconception that all Chinese
languages are exactly the same except
for their pronunciation the fact is
Chinese languages often differ in
grammar and vocabulary as well as
pronunciation the various forms of
written vernacular Chinese that
developed alongside classical Chinese
still exist today alongside standard
Chinese they're only used in some
limited situations but Cantonese in
particular is fairly widely used from
what I understand most of the characters
used are the same but they'll be
pronounced differently and some
different characters might be used to
represent the different vocabulary and
the order of the characters might be
different to represent the different
syntax pronunciation as previously
mentioned Chinese languages are tonal
that means that tones are one part of
the pronunciation that can change the
meaning of a word the same written word
can be pronounced very differently in
different Chinese languages this is the
word for telephone first in Mandarin
PMOI next in Cantonese in LA in
Shanghainese tu and in Hakka yah-ha let
me explain a little further Mandarin has
four main tones plus one neutral tone
the tones are number one a high flat
tone to a rising tone three a falling
rising tone for a falling tone and five
the neutral tone meaning that SIL
is not distinguished by tone at all
ma-ma-ma-ma-ma
now captain Eve has picked on the six
cancer these stones are number one a
high flat tone too amid rising tone
three a mid flat tone for a low falling
tone five a low rising tone and fix a
low flat tone si si si si si si
Shanghainese has a different type of
tone system entirely it's more of a
pitch accent system like Japanese there
are really only two tones high and low
and the tone of the first syllable
determines the tone pattern of the
following syllables do you hear the
first syllable has a low tone which
depends on the character that makes the
second syllable high and it doesn't
matter what character it is tone is only
connected to meaning in the first
syllable word order
there are both similarities and
differences in the word order of Chinese
languages Mandarin is generally SVO
though it's sov in some structures and
Cantonese is also SVO more so than
Mandarin Shanghainese and other wu
dialects are both SVO and sov so in
mandarin we have four who call it true
which means I drink juice here's the
subject verb and object and in Cantonese
no Liam pull it up again subject verb
object and now in Shanghainese boota
boota in these examples it turns out
that the word order is the same but
notice that each language uses a
different character for the verb to
reflect different vocabulary let's look
at another element of word order
Mandarin places an indirect object
before the direct object
Cantonese places it after the direct
object like in this sentence which means
give me the book in Mandarin game off
and chew the word forward it gives me
book and in Cantonese a pronoun signal
word for word it gives book me and if
you imagine a 2 in there it's like give
book to me also notice the character for
give is different here
and then Shanghainese open soon hear the
word order is like Mandarin but notice
the different word forgives and the
variant character for me another example
difference Mandarin or standard Chinese
places the adverb before the verb the
sentence means I'll go first
in membranous or hints all recorded I
first go
but Cantonese places the adverb after
the verb all telecine were forwarded I
go first and in Shanghai knees push
about Tana here the main word order is
the same as Mandarin with the adverb
before the verb but notice the
additional particles at the end which
are for exclamation but don't have any
core meaning another example different
mandarin places the adjective after the
mount
so the phrase meaning strong wind in
mandarin is literally wind strong so how
Cantonese places the adjectives before
the noun so literally it's strong with
hold ISIL and in Shanghainese so now to
hear the adjective comes after the noun
just like in mandarin but notice that
one of the two characters is different
those are just a few samples of the
variation between the different chinese
languages and their dialects we could go
very deeply into these differences but
that's beyond the scope of this general
video one other difference we should
talk about though is that there are two
different systems for writing Chinese
characters there are traditional
characters the ones that are written as
they were in classical Chinese and then
there are simplified characters which
were created in the 1950s and 60s to
increase literacy simplified characters
are used in the People's Republic of
China and in Singapore traditional
characters are used in Taiwan and in
Hong Kong and Macau which were not under
Chinese rule when simplified characters
were introduced they are also used in
many Chinese diaspora communities here's
a traditional character on the left and
here's a simplified equivalent on the
right so you can see that they are
different and it's probably easier to
write the simplified one but despite the
differences literate native speakers
generally have no trouble reading either
type of character as you can see the
scientific language family which is
often called Chinese is a large dive
first group of languages and dialects
which are often unintelligible what
unites them all together is their shared
origin growing out of middle Chinese and
the classical Chinese literary tradition
and they're also united by a common
written language which is learned and
understood by speakers of all Chinese
varieties however even those speakers of
different Chinese languages can easily
communicate with each other in writing
that shared writing system isn't enough
to help them communicate verbally
without specifically learning Mandarin
this is a good reason to consider
Chinese a group of languages or a
language family rather than a single
language with many dialects so the
question of the day to native speakers
of any variety of Chinese you consider
Chinese to be a group of distinct
languages or do you consider it one
language with a lot of dialectal
variation and I'm just asking you to
explain the way that you personally
think about it so there's no right or
wrong answer here and for people who
have studied any variety of Chinese just
tell us something that you've found
fascinating about your journey with that
language be sure to follow Lange focus
on Facebook Twitter and Instagram and
once again I'd like to say thank you to
all of my fantastic patreon supporters
especially these amazing people right
here on the screen thank you for
watching and have a nice day
[Music]